[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour cette
fois en question cette option se fois en
question nous accueillons aujourd'hui le
docteur amélie bodin amélie bonjour
bonjour julien donc amélie qui est post
doc à l'université de vie de bathurst
rendre en afrique du sud et qui a le
privilège de travailler directement sur
le squelette de little foot alors amélie
peut-être avant justement de commencer
par parler de ton travail est-ce que tu
ne peux nous expliquer ce que c'est que
little foot clietèle foot est un
squelette d'australopithèque dans les
premiers restes ont été découverts il ya
plus de 20 ans mais le squelette entier
a été exhumée donc l'année dernière est
présentée au public l'année dernière et
little foot est un fait une femelle qui
a vécu il ya environ 3,6 millions
d'années en afrique du sud
comment on sait que c'est une femelle
little foot parce que du coup en
français on l'appelle petit pied mais du
coup ce serait petit pied c'est ça ou
billy talent shooter est une femelle
puisqu'on a pu observer notamment sa
dentition donc on sait que les exemples
les canines nous donne des informations
sur le sexe pas seulement d au minimum
est de prime est en général donc avec à
la fois sa dentition mais également la
morphologie de son bassin on peut en
déduire que little foot était une
femelle d'accord sur un peu l'historique
de la découverte parce que little foot
c'est une arlésienne c'est un truc qui a
traîné pendant presque vingt ans donc en
premier ce que ce que ron clark donc
chercheurs dans la même université avait
découvert c'était c'était juste des os
du pied c'est pour ça qu'on l'appelle it
all foot c'est ça voilà c'est ça les
premiers zoo en fait qui ont été
retrouvés de little foutons qui étaient
les eaux des os du pied donc saison ont
été retrouvés par anne clark à
l'université dans les collections
d'abord il s'était retrouvé en fête dans
une boîte où était conservé la faune et
donc à partir de ces eaux
ron retrouvez donc ces ossements domine
décidée en fait de retourner dans la
grotte pour essayer de retrouver la
suite du squelette du spécimen donc la
fée des moulages réaliser des moulages
de ses os du pied a donné les moulages à
ses assistants qui sont ensuite
retournés dans la grotte et ont pu
retrouver leur est un fait du pied qui
était encore enfermés dans la roche et
ensuite petit à petit donc ils ont peu à
peu découvert le reste du squelette donc
pas tout d'un bloc il a tout d'abord
fallu donc retrouver la jonction entre
saison retrouver dans les boîtes et donc
là le reste de la jambe ensuite à partir
de là donc ils ont retrouvé la suite
désolons des membres inférieurs ensuite
il manquait donc une grosse partie qui
n'étaient pas en connexion pète avec les
gens dans tout ce qui est donc mort liée
au bassin 27 parties étaient effondrés
donc un peu en dessous des dépôts du
pied et donc ils ont retrouvé ensuite la
suite du bassin et petit à petit son
arrivée jusqu'au crâne et donc pour
extraire l'ensemble du squelette il a
fallu plus de vingt ans puisque les eaux
est encore dans la brèche et donc tout
l'enjeu était de pouvoir extraire les
eaux de façon à récupérer lorsque la
tente c'est à dire sans l'abîmer et sans
le sans provoquer de dommages en fait
sur le spécimen donc tout l'enjeu était
de fait de faire des folies donc très
minutieuse et donc d'utiliser des outils
notamment comme une fraiseuse de
dentiste donc d'où là en fait la durée
de ces foutus on dirait donc plus de 20
ans ouais donc pour ceux qui qui sont
pas géologue parmi nous la brèche c'est
quoi c'est une robe c'est un genre de
d'éboulis mais qui a été de burcy alors
les huiles avec little foot on est dans
un contexte un peu particulier donc
contexte en fait sud africain où les
ossements domine se retrouver dans des
grottes qui ont été remplies au fur et à
mesure du temps donc ces grottes il faut
imaginer autant de little foot donc des
trous dans le sol où les animaux dont
pouvait tomber donc c'était notamment le
cas de little foot ou bien les restes
les cadavres en fait des animaux en
surface pouvait être charriés par la
pluie est tombée dans le trou au fur et
à mesure en fait ces grottes ont été
remplies avec les restes de l'extérieur
ou des animaux qui tombait ou bien même
avec des prédateurs qui ramenait donc
les dépouilles de leurs proies dans les
grottes d'un petit à petit on a ce
remplissage qui à la fois donc des
restes d'animaux mais également
des sédiments donc qu'ils peuvent être
amenées l'extérieur ou bien des
sédiments de la grotte avec donc tout
processus de formation des sédiments
grotte c'est à dire des mélanges dont
des ruissellements d'eau qui sont
chargés en certains minéraux
petit à petit la grotte se remplit
jusqu'à ce qu'elles soient complètement
fermée et en suit donc avec les
processus d'érosion les les restes fin
le remplissage de la grotte affleurent à
la surface et c'est comme ça qu'on peut
retrouver donc il reste par exemple de
little shoot d'accord dans ce qu'on
retrouve à la fin en fait c'est le
remplissage de la grotte qui finalement
dépasse de la montagne mais ça on
retrouve ce que le reste de leur est a
été complètement érodée en fait voilà en
fait ce qui est surtout héros dc le
toile à la grotte
il faut imaginer donc la grotte rempli
jusqu'à l'ouverture en fait original et
ensuite donc l'érosion des caps le toit
de la grotte et petit à petit on arrive
au niveau qui contiennent des défauts
s'illumine d'accord justement little
foot donc tu as dit dans ces trous il ya
de tout un tas d'animaux qui tombe
melita foot était le solo minime de ça
alain dans les niveaux niveaux
stratigraphique niveau géologique ou
litas foot a été découvert qu'il n'y a
pas d'autres mini jusqu'à aujourd'hui
est par contre on a retrouvé des restes
de bavoirs ya énormément de restes de
babouins qui sont associés à beatles
photons cas de la faune il ya d'autres
animaux autour mais pour l'instant
little foot est le seul où meaning de ce
niveau géologique et on a une idée de
pourquoi pas ce que c'est parce que les
niveaux sont trois anciens pour contenir
des homininés à ce que c'est parce que
il y avait une sorte de sélectivité à
l'entrée il y avait un videur alors ça
ça paraît un peu surprenant qu'ils aient
qu'un sallaumines in sachant que sur
d'autres niveaux par exemple plus récent
comme les membres 4 on n'a plus du bilan
reste homing qui ont été découverts donc
ça pose surtout des questions sur ce
qu'on appelle la taphonomie c'est à dire
comment en fait c'est ces fossiles sont
devenus fossile donc comment on va tous
ces niveaux sont se sont formés donc ça
c'est le travail un peu des géologues
jowhar colloque de comprendre la
formation de cette couche géologique
donc pour little foot il ya vraiment un
degré de réservation qui est assez
exceptionnel ce qui pourrait expliquer
pourquoi on n'est qu'un slot mini ce que
lidl foot donc et le est presque complet
dont compris à presque 90 % et d'avoir
tout ce squelette conserver ça en fait
impliquerait qu'ils aient des conditions
de conservation des conditions de
fossilisation qui sont assez unique dans
une plainte aux questions du cap en
afrique du sud puisque on retrouve donc
ce niveau de conservation d'une part
ailleurs donc on va tous toutes ces
niveaux donc c'est de ce devrait être
conservation cette taxonomie est
peut-être unique en fait à little foot
mais bon pour l'instant d'accord c'est
trop nouveau pour savoir pour l'instant
déjà rassurez vous il reste du boulot
pour nos auditeurs
amélie vient de nous dire quand même que
little foot est complet à 90 % alors la
plupart des gens connaissent
l'uci est d'ailleurs la plupart des gens
ne connaissent que lucie canton quand il
s'agit des australopithèques donc déjà
des australopithèques en existe
certainement au moins une bonne dizaine
d'espèces et et lucie donc
australopithecus afarensis elle est
complète à 40% donc little foot on est
face à un squelette qui est quasiment
complet y manque wahba juste les
morceaux du pied en fait qu les rotules
et des rotules compétir trouvé d'accord
et ont eu quelques jeux du piège donc
quelques os du pied qui était
certainement préservé mais qui ont été
certainement fin qui ont été perdus
avant avant que ron clark ne retrouve
les morceaux dans la boîte
dans la petite boîte à l'université ce
que dit le
donc la grotte de little foot on a été
tout d'abord exploité pour son minerai
donc parler car les outils utilisés par
des explosifs donc il ya beaucoup de
faux si la star fontaine pas seulement
little foot mais je m'étais retrouvé à
cause de ses activités là en fait de ses
exploits explosifs qui ont en fait
dégager des ossements d'homininés c'est
comme ça qu'on sait voilà la star
fontaine qu'on a découvert pour la
première fois les les restes de domini
donc pour little foot ça est exactement
le même contexte donc c'est d'abord les
mineurs qui ont les carriers qui ont en
fait extraire le minerai et qui ont mis
au jour donc les os du pied de little
foot donc probablement les eaux qui
manquent
on était en fait dégagé par l'explosif
et donc on les retrouvera pas par contre
pour les rotules selon ron clark il
serait toujours possible de les
retrouver ce qu'elles ont été elles
étaient encore dans la brèche comme le
reste du squelette mais ça nécessite un
fait de fouiller la brèche
autour de little foot donc ça représente
un travail qui est assez conséquent mais
pourquoi pas peut-être dans les années à
venir on pourrait retrouver le recul de
little foot j'anticipe les petits
rigolos qui veulent retrouver le bas qu
l'homme de bittle foot c'est une femelle
on l'a déjà dit donc voilà ok donc où
est la préservation exceptionnelles donc
à fossiles complet à 90 % comparé à lui
si c'est beaucoup plus en plus lui s'il
ya des morceaux de babouins donc ce qui
a deux exceptionnels aussi c'est que
tout ou presque était en articulation
tout était en connexion ou très proches
donc les eaux étaient très proches les
uns des autres car il ya quand même eu
de mouvement avec par exemple des eaux
qui n'était pas en place donc par
exemple il ya un des bras de little foot
qui était en fait dans le dans le crâne
enfin retrouvé en partie dans le dans le
crâne donc il ya quand même des
mouvements des ossements mais ils ont
été vraiment conservé presque en
connexion et donc si ça aussi ce ça
explique aussi le commander
en fait le degré de préservation aussi
toute la fossilise les conditions de
fossilisation de little foot qui ont
permis en fait de retrouver ce squelette
en connexion donc il ya vraiment
probablement les chercheurs pensent oui
taf économistes pensent qu'il ya eu un
processus de momification en fait avant
la fossilisation et ça expliquerait
pourquoi on est ce squelette aussi bien
conservé d'accord les chèvres ont retenu
les autres c'est sa double ever ensemble
d'accords est du coup il ya une chance
de trouver plus de dominer ou à quel
point on en est de la fouille de cette
grotte tags les fruits sont cons ces
retraits pour l'instant sur little foot
donc les barbes relève avant que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure qui ont été
retrouvés ils ont été retrouvées
vraiment sous little food en fait c'est
comme ça qu'on corps en cas claironne
clark les a retrouvés c'est pendant la
fouille de little foot en fait il ya
d'autres restes de primates qui vont un
peu émergé qui était derrière
donc pour l'instant c'est voit les
fruits sont vraiment concentrés sur
cette zone lac qui contient le foot il
ya une série d'articles là qui viennent
d'être publiées à propos de little foot
dont tué au moins 1 coauteur ou auteur
principal donc toi quel a été ton
travail sur les taux de foot
donc moi mon rôle dans l'équipe de stars
fontaine qui travaillent sur little foot
ça a été avant de fou de donc de
participer à la description du squelette
mais aussi d'aller plus loin en
utilisant des techniques d'imagerie
comme des scanners pour pouvoir extraire
un maximum d'informations du ska de
little foot donc comme disait le
squelette est vraiment exceptionnel par
sa reconversion est donc là tout l'enjeu
de little foot c'est maintenant de
dexter un maximum d'informations de ce
squelette qui préserve à la fois le
crâne elle pose crâne donc ça nous
permet d'étudier par exemple la
locomotion chez un individu où on a le
crâne donc on peut définir à la fois son
espèce et discuter de sa locomotion dans
ce qui ce qui est ce qui arrive presque
parce que jamais donc c'est tout
l'intérêt de little foot et aussi de
participer à ces débats il ya de
nombreux débats donc pas ne passons pas
seulement pour australopithèques mais
par exemple pour part entre hop on n'a
aucun crâne presque associé à du post
crânien et donc par exemple dans ce cas
là on peut très bien discuter du poste
craignent à la locomotion on pourra
jamais l'associer à une espèce précise
on pourra jamais dire c'est tel groupe
de part entre la hausse rapide et qu'on
a à peu près
on a à peu près les mêmes débats donc là
ça va permettre vraiment avec little
foot de discuter d'un comportement chez
une espèce particulière à un temps donné
ce qu'on puisse on a des bonnes datation
produits etl foot et donc oui avec
l'utilisation des scanners on peut aller
encore plus loin et est vraiment extra
un maximum d'informations du top foot
vont pousser au maximum la potentialité
de little foot et donc avec le scanner
donc on a pu vraiment explorer donc là
pour à ce stade donc les nos efforts
sont concentrés sur le crâne donc moi
j'ai participé à la description du crâne
notamment ses structures internes ce qui
avec le scanner on a pu donc j'ai pu
reconstruire en fait une copie de alors
pas du cerveau en tant que tel en tout
cas des empreintes du cerveau qui sont
conservés dans le crâne de little foot
donc encore une fois avec le crâne de
little foot on a encore une fois un
individu exceptionnel ce que le freiner
et complet tout ce qui arrive presque
jamais à cette période de trois millions
d'années
donc là pour la première fois en un an
de crâne complet d'un australopithèque
de plus de trois millions d'années
donc ça nous permet en fait de vraiment
extraire toutes les informations donc
les empreintes du cerveau de ce spécimen
est pouvoir discuter donc de son de la
morphologie de son crâne et mais
également de son organisation donc là on
aurait fait tout l'enjeu est de
comprendre comment finalement à quoi
ressemble et le cerveau d'un drop it est
qu à cette époque là voici de comprendre
aussi son évolution l'évolution du
cerveau dans toute notre ligne est donc
dans toute notre famille pour essayer de
comprendre les caractéristiques humaines
donc en gros si je comprends bien c'est
la première fois finalement qu'on peut
associer une morphologie de cerveau avec
des caractères donc du squelette post
kranja c'est à dire que en gros par
exemple quand on étudie les parents
trope ce que tu disais on peut voir leur
cerveau mais on peut pas associer telle
partie du cerveau avec
le comportement on peut voir des départs
entre up qui se suspendent aux arbres
dans l'est dans les documentaires en
fait on n'en sait rien parce qu'on n'a
pas leur squelette donc on sait pas s'il
en était capable
mais la grâce à little foot du coup on
pourrait associer finale déjà on peut
associer le les comportements qu'on peut
qu on peut reconstituer à partir du
squelette à une espèce donnée dont on a
le squelette entier et en plus
maintenant tu peux étudier aussi le
comment ça ça correspond avec le cerveau
c'est ça voilà exactement qu'on peut
combiner des informations qui
proviennent du crâne et du post crânien
donc discuter donc ces problématiques de
locomotion et au delà du cerveau donc
qui peut nous donner des indications sur
les fonctions qui sont liées par exemple
à la motricité donc à la locomotion
on a aussi un autre élément qui peut
nous permettre de discuter de ces
questions c'est le l'oreille interne
michelito la faute on a aussi retrouvé
un une oreille interne l'oreillette
droite qui est complète donc là
l'intérêt de l'oreille interne c'est
qu'on sait qu'elle est relié à ce qui
concerne l' équilibre donc indirectement
d'un des informations sur les mouvements
du notamment de la tête c'est aussi du
nom la locomotion en général j'ai il te
le foot et chez les australopithèques
donc on peut qu'on dit combiner toutes
ces évidences donc à la fois du cerveau
l'oreille interne et du post crânien
pour essayer de comprendre comment ils
te le foot se déplacer dans son
environnement et c'est la première fois
qu'on peut le faire avec un tel niveau
de précision
donc la wii en plus d'avoir le poste
crâne et donc des indices par exemple
qui proviennent de l'oreille interne
donc là c'est la première fois qu'on
peut l'associer chez un seul individu
donc là c'est tout l'intérêt aussi de
deux dents notre équipe de combiner
différentes études
quelle éthique du post crâneur en partie
qui a été en particulier en partie
publiée
donc là il ya très peu de temps donc on
peut combiner voilà et stc 10 des
hypothèses est là aussi pour
australopithèques la question qui se
pose donc on sait que les
australopithèques était bipède terrestre
et qui ose qui passaient aussi un
certain temps dans les arbres ne sais
pas dans quelle proportion
ça ça pose des questions
ces importantes pour le mode de vie des
australopithèques pour savoir s'ils
passaient tout leur temps sur le sol et
grimper dans les arbres par exemple
juste pour fuir les prédateurs ou bien
s'ils passaient plus de temps dans les
arbres pour par exemple rechercher la
nourriture et un peu moins de temps dans
l'est sur le sol ça ces questions
jusqu'à maintenant on n'a pas vraiment
d'idée de ces proportions dans les
comportements
donc la lutte le foot de nouveau va nous
apporter des informations et on va
pouvoir comprendre qu'elle était
vraiment là en mode de vie et lorsque
l'on pourrait dire finalement leur
écologie donc comment commencer ces
individus vivait il ya plus trois
millions d'années mais alors du coup
qu'est ce qui nous apprend ce très beau
but à klaas là on entend des belles
promesses mais concrètement qu'est ce
qui nous apprend donc là par exemple
poule alors un des éléments qui est
nouveau avec little foot c'est qu'on a
donc les membres inférieurs et
supérieurs complet donc on va pouvoir
comparer les proportions
donc ce qu'on pouvait pas forcément
faire donc on a bien sûr lui s'y met lui
si elle est complète cac 40 % donc ça
nous donnait vraiment une idée assez
vague là ce qu'on peut voir un mec
little foot c'est que finalement les
proportions dans les membres elles sont
assez proches des humains actuels donc
là on va pouvoir aussi de nous de
nouveau essayer de comprendre comment
cette évolution elle s'est déroulée dans
notre famille et finalement comment
peut-être c'est de comprendre avant
little foot puisque littlejohn
instantané à trois millions d'années
mais on peut essayer aussi développé des
hypothèses à skis pour savoir ce qui
s'est passé avant little foot donc avec
nos ancêtres communs par exemple avec
les chimpanzés actuelle savoir comment
finalement comment à quoi il ressemblait
aussi savoir leur mode de vie essayer de
comprendre ce qui a fait qu'on a une
telle évolution dans notre ligne est par
exemple pas chez les champions donc il
te le foot avec avait les bras plus
court que les jambes c'est ça donc on
pourrait partir sur du bipède confirmé
quoi
oui un rom sable d'après les études en
fait des restes qui étaient déjà
disponibles on sait avec
australopithèques était bipède pratiquer
une bipédie ou pas aussi efficace que la
nôtre en terme de biomécanique
mais on a il ya quand même une bipédie
donc bobby bedi efficace mais par contre
lidl foot et les autres à pita qu'en
général vous pouvez pas pratiquer des
activités comme par exemple la course ça
c'est une spécificité très humaine donc
une bipédie qui ont en fait plutôt que
parler d' une bipédie faudrait plutôt
parler débit
certainement plusieurs bipédie dans
notre famille mais aussi en général chez
les hominoïdes donc on peut dire que
willy talent foot et sera pittet qui
était bipède d'accord et du coup sur le
cerveau toi tu as trouvé quoi impôts le
cerveau donc l'as cannes c'est
intéressant c'est que pour la première
fois on a vraiment le cerveau entier et
donc ce qui a été intéressant de voir
c'est est de comparer les différentes
aires cérébrales entre l une des
questions conquis vin qui est assez
importante empalot paléoanthropologie
c'est de savoir si le cerveau dans notre
ligne et a évolué donc d'une façon un
peu linéaire c'est à dire que tout le
cerveau a changé en même temps ou alors
s'il ya certaines aires du cerveau qui
ont évolué avant d'autres donc ça c'est
intéressant puisqu'on va pouvoir le
relier à des fonctions par exemple si
c'est plutôt l'art visuel qui a évolué
en premier peut-être que ces liens et
changements dans l'environnement à des
changements dans les ressources donc
pour adapter sa vision à certains types
d'aliments donc avec little foot ce
qu'on a pu voir c'est que l'air frontale
donc la partie avant du cerveau elle est
très proche de ce qu'on observe chez les
autres australopithèques c'est à dire
une heure relativement on va dire proche
de du pape ce qu'on dit patrie
ancestrale en fait de l'ancêtre commun
avec les chimpanzés actuelle donc on n'a
vraiment pas là la structure typique
qu'on observe chez les humains actuels
en revanche pour la partie plutôt
arrière donc c'est lui justement qui
contient les arts visuels
on observe vraiment une organisation qui
encore qui est très différente des
australopithèques plus récent
puisqu'elle est très juste très proche
des chimpanzés actuelle aux salaires on
a une heure visuel qui est assez assez
étendu ce qui représente une bonne
proportion en pet du cerveau et donc ça
c'est quelque chose qu'on ne savent pas
chez les australopithèques plus récents
et notamment chez les humains actuels ou
là on a une aire visuel qui est réduite
puisque l'air en fait qu'on appelle
l'art pariétal monclar qui est un peu au
milieu du cerveau elle est beaucoup plus
étendu et cet argent c'est qu'elle est
liée à la motricité par exemple donc on
a vraiment chez lidl foot qui a encore
un cerveau qui est très proche de ce
qu'on observe chez nos plus proches
parents actuellement chez les chimpanzés
qui est pas aussi réorganiser que ce
qu'on observe chez les australopithèques
plus plus récents ou même chez les
chaînes du minck
dernière question et c'est la question
que tout le monde attend
la question de l'identité de little foot
quelle quelle espèce était little foot
alors on entend beaucoup parler d'eux
australopithecus prometheus mais je suis
sûr qu'il ya beaucoup de nos auditeurs
qui on peut lire ici et là que little
foot pourrait aussi être une nouvelle
espèce alors est-ce que tu peu à peu
nous aider à clarifier tout ça enfin
faut remettre ça dans le contexte qu'en
fait little foot est plus vieux que la
plupart des australopithèques c'est ça
c'est 3,7 millions d'années alors donc
little foot c'est oui à 3,6 millions
d'années en afrique de l'est il ya aussi
d'autres ce serait happy tac cette
période donc notamment - lucic un peu un
peu plus jeunes mais on a nos dossards
epitech qui sont attribués à
australopithecus afarensis en afrique du
sud
on connaît surtout australopithecus
africanus stade heures l'enfant de temps
ou mi6 pièces appartiennent à ce groupe
de se répéter que ce africanews de la
l'hypothèse qui est défendue notamment
par ron clark et que little foot
appartiendrait à se répéter cus
prometheus qui qu'on retrouverait
éventuellement aussi dans des niveaux
géologiques où on observe ce rapide et
que ce africanus notamment star fontaine
c'est à dire que là l'hypothèse c'est
vraiment une autre espèce qui continue à
évoluer alors qu'il ya aussi ce serait
plutôt que ce africanews le prometheus
est pas une nouvelle espèce donc
prometheus n'est pas une nouvelle espèce
qui l'a été cette espèce à elle a été
introduite par mondes art dans les
années 40 à partir d'un fossile donc pas
de stars fontaine pas de là où vient
little foot mais de ma cabane
mais quand même strate qui est aussi
dans le berceau de l'humanité et donc il
a proposé à partir de serre est une
nouvelle espèce qu'il serait
australopithecus prometheus donc par la
suite historiquement ces restes ont ils
ont été réattribués a aussi répété cus
africanus donc là c'est le l'hypothèse
de ron kirk s'est de ressusciter cette
espèce et pouvoir attribuer donc little
foot mais pas encore une fois pas
seulement l'idée le foot aussi d'autres
spécimens
un peu moins connus parce que ça surtout
de res crânien à de les ré attribuées à
cette espèce prometheus donc là aussi le
tout l'enjeu c'est de savoir qu donc
l'hypothèse de prometheus
elle implique aussi d'autres hypothèses
qui sont assez importantes au niveau de
xiamen nous ce serait que prometheus
donc lidl foot serait un c sera lé
notamment dont cap serait l'ancêtre
aussi de pas rentrer plus c'est voilà
tout l'enjeu en fait de pouvoir de
proposer une nouvelle espèce et que
c'est pas juste un nom il ya aussi plein
d'applications derrière notamment en
termes d'évolution et prometheus est
notamment a été décrit par un clark sur
le fait que donc cette espèce a des
caractères strapi tech mais également
des caractères part entre up donc nous
aussi l'hypothèse d'un ancêtre de
parents trop plus d'accord dans qu'est
ce qu'ils feraient de de little foot
enfin de d'australopithecus prometheus
un une espèce à part
quelles sont les caractéristiques qu'on
lui attribue alors là encore une fois
selon donc ron clark qui donc a attribué
lidl fouta prometheus il exposera il
propose un certain nombre de caractères
dombiste de caractère qui sont surtout
crâne
donc c'est des caractères pas assez
qualitatif c'est à dire par exemple un
des caractères qui serait marqueur de
pro b tu ce serait le développement de
la glabelle donc du point qui entre les
orbites qui serait plus prononcée chez
prometheus par rapport à fric à nous
c'est aussi dit par exemple le
développement du dollar masto ide qui
sera aussi en co-op plus bombée chez pas
entre ge et prometheus que chez
africanus donc il avait toute une série
de caractères crânien qui que ron clark
d'entre eux proposent comme étant
discriminant et pouvant définir une
nouvelle espèce quand même fait ce sont
surtout des caractères pour l'instant
qualitatif donc bien sûr à cette
description ça ajoutera par la suite des
mesures d'aidé description plutôt
quantitative ou l'un pourra vraiment
confrontés donc tester cette hypothèse
et en comparant avec d'autres spécimens
non pas seulement en afrique du sud mais
aussi d'afrique de l'est et peser
vraiment la question ce que la question
centrale
non pour savoir si on a une nouvelle
espèce ou pas c'est aussi parler de la
variabilité le problème qu'on a c'est
chez les féminines fossiles bouge comme
tous les groupes des groupes fossiles
qu'on n'est pas finalement
bien la variabilité c'est à dire que
dans une espèce on peut avoir une très
grande variabilité ça reste toujours une
espèce donc là l'enjeu est de savoir si
la variabilité qu'on observe par exemple
si ces australopithèques elle justifie
cette existence de deux espèces
différentes ou pas donc là cette
question elle nécessite un certain
nombre de mesures pas forcément
crânienne mais de vraiment combiner
toutes ces informations est un gros
travail aussi comparatif avec les autres
spécimens qu'on a les autres aussi qu'on
a de cette période et des périodes de
six plus récents de voir plus en scène
d'accord donc pour répondre à la
question de façon très courte
non c'est pas une nouvelle espèce et la
résurrection d'une vieille espèces mais
du coup ça prouve toute entente question
en fait mais c'est ça ça mais ça a le
mérite d'être une hypothèse qu'on peut
tester donc c'est intéressant
rocard propose une hypothèse donc de
réutiliser une ancienne espèce qui avait
été décrite par mondes art en avec donc
un certain nombre de spécimens qui
pourrait pas de prétendre à être
appartenir à cette espèce de bête ça ça
reste assez théorique c'est une
hypothèse qu'on pourra que voilà tous
les chercheurs pourront tester en
apportant leurs mesures et leur
contribution la révision et little foot
mais cas qu'au delà des questions et des
dires des débats sur une nouvelle espèce
manoel espèces lidl foot ça reste un
spécimen majeur en pas l'anthropologie
gantois part parce que on a là vraiment
un squelette presque complet et c'est
bien sûr ça peut nous apporter des
informations sur ce qu'on appelle à peu
diversité donc le nombre d'espèces qu'on
a et c
mais le plus important c'est aussi de
comprendre leur biologie finalement
comment comment il doit le fouta a vécu
et c'est moi je pensais ces questions là
qui sont un peu centrale c'est vraiment
de comprendre avec little foot on peut
aussi comprendre qu est ce qui fait qu
est ce qui contribue à notre spécificité
à nous en tant qu'humain ce qui fait
qu'on est là aujourd'hui et finalement
comment on a évolué dans le temps
il ya aussi avec little foot on a si je
pense des nouvelles informations sur
aussi comment les au mini pouvaient
interagir avec leur environnement
ça aussi qui est passionnant avec son
squelette on peut discuter de la
locomotion dont 2 comment ils se
déplacent dans l'environnement de
l'alimentation des ressources qui puise
dans l'environnement ça ça participe à
mieux comprendre finalement nos ancêtres
d'accord donc la taxonomie finalement ce
n'est que le début de
de l'histoire après il ya tout ce qui se
cache derrière qui est tout aussi voire
plus fascinants encore alors petit
rajout petit adam d'hommes durant le
montage de cette interview puisque alors
que j'étais en train de faire le montage
de la vidéo il y à un nouvel article qui
est sorti et qui propose qu'en fait
australopithecus prometheus c'est-à-dire
l'espèce à laquelle little foot
appartiendrait et bien en fait cette
espèce n'existerait pas alors comment
c'est possible ça tout simplement parce
que quand on quand raymonde art a créé
la nouvelle espèce d'australopithèque us
prometheus en 1948
eh bien il lui a donné un spécimen de
référence un spécimen qu'on appelle le
lot type
le spécimen de référence ou lolo type et
bien c'est un spécimen en fait qui va
servir de comparaison de base et à
chaque fois qu'un nouveau fossile va
ressembler plus à ce fossile la cas
n'importe quel autre fossile
d'australopithèques eh bien on va les
attribuer à australopithecus prometheus
donc ça spécimens qui est extrêmement
important et le problème c'est que cette
importance n'est pas du tout compensé
par la qualité du matériel dans le cas
d'un australopithèque us prometheus
puisque il s'agit d'un tout petit bout
de crâne à peine identifiables comme
étant celui d'un australopithèque c'est
juste un petit fragment de boîte
crânienne et on peut deviner que le
cerveau était suffisamment gros pour
dire que c'était un australopithèque
donc voilà c'est pas exactement le
matériel idéal pour créer un nouveau
type d'une nouvelle espèce et raymonde
art lui même l'avait reconnu avait
abandonné l'espèce australopithecus
prometheus mais en ressuscitant
australopithecus prometheus ron clark a
aussi ressuscité ce spécimen comme le
type et le problème c'est que ron clark
du coup a attribué un matériel
extrêmement complet donc little foot
un squelette complet à 90 % à une espèce
qui n'est normalement représenté que par
un tout petit bout de crâne et donc ça
d'après l'iburger et john hawkes les
auteurs de cet article
et bah c'est un problème c'est un
problème parce qu'on a engrossé on
n'attribue pas du très beau matériel à
une espèce qui est représenté par du
très mauvais matériel normalement on
attribue le très mauvais matériel à
l'espèce qui représentait part du très
beau matériel et encore si on arrive à
trouver des caractères diagnostic
donc même si ce nouvel article ne traite
pas directement de little foot
il a son importance dans le contexte de
cette discussion que nous avons
u avec amélie à propos de little foot et
du coup j'ai demandé à amélie son
opinion à propos de ce nouvel article
donc en écoute
amélie oui cet article de libé rigueur
et john hawkes soulève le problème du
non d'australopithecus prometteuse donc
dans cet article il rappelle surtout le
historique derrière ce nom derrière le
nom de cet espace que finalement c'est
ce qui pose le plus de problème donc
prometheus a été proposé à l'origine par
mondes art quand il a travaillé donc sur
le site de ma cape en strates où il a
retrouvé un spécimen notamment qui est
mld un qui est un os au défunt parti la
partie occidentale du crâne dont cas
particulier à l'arrière d'un individu je
vais venir et donc à partir des
différences que lui a pu observer entre
ce spécimen et d'autres spécimens
notamment l'enfant notant qu il a décidé
de créer une nouvelle espèce qui était
donc on se répéter que ce prometheus
donc assez rapidement il a abandonné un
peu cette espèce on compte trois en plus
de spécimens dans prometheus a disparu
et ron clark en fête propose lui de
ressusciter un peu le nom de cette
espèce pour donc pour pouvoir un peu
accommoder puisqu'il observe une
certaine line certaine variabilité au
sein d'australopithecus notamment à 7 à
fontaine et de cette réhabilité il en
déduit qu'il y aurait donc deux espèces
aster fontaine qui serait africanus donc
mais se blesse et prometheus dans lequel
il classe notamment invita le foot donc
là la question l'article était de savoir
si cette espèce est valide puisque le
problème qui se pose c'est que y'a pas
on n'a pas de description de diagnose
scientifique qui associé à prometheus
donc d'arte au moment où il a nommé
cette espèce n'a pas produit de
description donc on ne peut pas
réutiliser en fait c'est cette
description pour savoir pour classer
maintenant les spécimens comme étant
prometheus ou non donc en fait ce qu'il
propose c'est que tant qu'on n'a pas
tant que les chercheurs de mettre en
place une
diagnos fiable qui respecte les règles
notamment nomenclature en zoologie
on ne peut pas être capable d'utiliser
cette espèce cet espace n'est pas valide
donc on peut pas dire qu'un spécimen
appartient un premier du nom enfin
cesser leur donc leur leurs propositions
donc c'est ce qu'ils reprochent
notamment à des d'autres chercheurs
comme par exemple ron clark de
d'utiliser cette espèce dans leurs
articles sont forcément l'associer à une
description donc l'article après le
mérite d'aborder cette question de
savoir comment comment nommer nommer
cette espèce est ce qu'on peut vraiment
utiliser prometheus ou non à présent ils
évoquent dans l'article et c'est
peut-être moi mon sens ce qui est plus
intéressant c'est de savoir sa
discussion autour de prometteuse surtout
une description de savoir s'il ya
d'autres espèces d'australopithecus à
cet art fontaine et notamment dans le
berceau de l'humanité donc en dehors de
sediba donc surtout ce qu'il ya derrière
c'est finalement la question de la
viabilité en
paléontologie aussi de la notion
d'espèce un pâle anthologie est de
savoir de comment
interpréter cette cette variabilité les
différences morphologiques on peut
observer dans le registre fossile donc
ça c'est peut-être qu'il est plus
important et ensuite il insiste aussi
beaucoup sur l'aspect sur comment
formaliser en fait ces observations et
comment les mettre
comment les organiser de façon à ce que
peuvent être utilisés par d'autres
chercheurs dans les discussions
dans les discussions scientifiques donc
merci amélie merci de nous avoir accordé
de ton temps on te souhaite beaucoup de
succès dans le futur et peut-être de
découvrir ton propre little foot je
l'espère en tout cas merci donc
et j'espère aussi qu'on reverra bientôt
sur la chaîne avec de nouvelles
découvertes avec piscine merci à tous et
à très bientôt sur stop science
[Musique]